your character eleth did you sort of
instantly know who this woman was I
think I did having sort of spent most of
my life in England people who've sort of
chilled me with their faint praise and
you know the things that you know
somebody says something you hear it and
you know that the words are
complimentary but you know that in the
delivery it's definitely not a
compliment you know when somebody says
oh how clever and you know that you've
done something wrong or it's not
pleasing and you don't know what it is
and it's it's saddening and makes you
feel very insecure and eleth was really
my chance to get back at all the people
who'd never made me feel
insecure um but it's a defense mechanism
you know we have to have empathy for her
because it's a massive defense mechanism
and I think that's what's so tragic
about her because when real tragedy
befalls her she's got no equipment to
deal with it at all